joining me today are two of the guys who
pulled off the biggest Sokol hoax since
well the original so-called hoax
Peter pegasion and James Lindsay welcome
to the Reuben report it's on I am happy
to have you guys here you're an old pro
around here it's good to be back yeah
pleasure your first time I'm enough I'm
all new well then with that spirit I'm
gonna ask you the first question for
people who have no idea what the
original Sokol hoax is because we're
obviously gonna spend a lot of time
talking about what you guys have done in
the last year what was the original
so-called hoax my people say oh they did
a Sokol hoax
what is that so Alan SoCo was a
physicist there is a physicist at NYU
and he in the 90s 95 96 he was looking
at this postmodern cultural criticism
and he was reading what they're doing
and they're using math words or using
physics ideas and terms and they're just
making up stuff you know like the sum
theorem about any sum theorem about
equality or inequalities and mathematics
and they'll say oh well this obviously
means that there's inequalities and you
know run with the the pun on inequality
and say some social stuff about it and
he started reading some of the stuff
that they were publishing I thought
there's no what not only are they
abusing science there's no way they even
understand what they're saying and he
wanted to check that out
so he wrote this paper transgressing the
boundaries toward at something what is
it a transformative hermeneutic of
quantum gravity
that sounds very it was it's to put it
more simply wanted to argue that quantum
gravity is a social construct of course
and so he did this thing he wrote this
complete nonsense paper what they call a
pastiche where he just took quotes from
the famous post modernists and filled in
with nonsense and use lots of
mathematical and physical you know
scientific words and misused them to say
goofy things and he sent it to a
preeminent social commentary post one or
social commentary journal at Duke
University social texts called social
texts and their editors accepted it and
published it and then the same day they
published it he came out and said ah you
know this was a fake he published an
expose article about it and so this is
why I did it ended up writing a
best-selling New York Times bestselling
book
called fashionable nonsense talking
about how these guys use these
fashionable terms and just say the right
political things and it's all nonsense
it doesn't really mean anything right
yeah so that was sort of the state of
you know what was going on in postmodern
cultural theory in the 1990s and he
struck a big blow against it big
controversy New York Times you know
front-page story all over the world
people dumping on him and some people
supporting him some people dumping on
him is a big mess so that was the
original hoax and he was trying to show
that you know they were abusing
scientific terminology taking out of the
scientific context and using it to make
political points for of course academic
leftist kind of fashionable points of
view right so this is a great precursor
to everything that you guys have done
because it's so consistent with the
conversations that we've been having for
years and so many of the conversations
I'm having on the show that this this
postmodern leftist orthodoxy it's
actually nonsense and and and you guys
set out to prove it was nonsense we did
yeah and the first time we wrote a paper
the conceptual penis is a social
construct and we argue that among other
things penises are responsible for
climate change and that that paper now
that's true but the rest of the paper
was completely relevant it came under
considerable criticism and so we took a
look at that criticism and we said okay
let's see if we can replicate this on a
grand scale so to be clear that was the
first one that you did where you were
trying to Peter yeah I did that one yeah
but that was the first one that you guys
did that you were trying to get through
this yeah that system yeah sure that
they couldn't distinguish between
made-up silliness and their own
scholarship yeah and then we we took a
look at that criticism and we decided to
replicate that on a massive scale yeah
so we wrote 20 papers in 10 months and
for context these are papers that go to
peer-reviewed journals seven papers in E
in seven years is tenure at most major
universities and we wrote with the help
of Helen pluck rose from aerial magazine
who in the UK is not here now obviously
we had seven of those published or
accepted for a publication and the Wall
Street Journal caught us we had seven
more under review or we were gonna
resubmit
okay so let's pause there for a second
tell me let's just go through some of
the greatest hits of these papers that
you got through I mean they're they're
quite brilliant but are there any that
you each like to tee off oh my gosh all
of them yes so the the most famous of
the papers as far as people having heard
about it was one Peter wrote the first
draft of and that was the the dog
humping paper as will refer to it
it was the paper was it called the title
we're performance idiot came rape
culture yeah or something like that the
fact that you can't quite remember the
name like they all have like the serious
subtitle and say I don't have a easy to
remember funny real title dog park as
well but we all we gave them all
nicknames and or code names or whatever
throughout so they're really the
nitty-gritty part like human
performativity and human reactions to
queer performativity and rape culture
and urban dog parks or whatever that's
all it's all just kind of scholarly
mishmash yeah it's hard to keep up with
but that paper is sort of the greatest
hit because not only was it accepted for
publication not only was it published
but the journal deemed that it was one
of the best papers and feminist
geography and gave it special
recognition was gonna gonna make a big
deal of it yeah we should lay out a
little more specifically what it is that
you were saying oh yeah so this is such
an important academia Ridge '''l point
of that paper was to argue that rape
culture is a big problem and the best
way that we could intervene upon that
would be to train men the way we train
dogs and so that was the original
concept and the idea was we're gonna
start with our conclusion and try to get
there how do we get to train men like we
trained dogs and so I told Pete because
he takes his dogs to the dog park every
day I said Pete use your experience in
the dog park maybe we get a dog training
manual and tried to figure it out from
there and so he goes off the dog
training manual thing just wasn't
working so he just starts writing his
experience but his experience this
absurd made-up
experience at the dog park about he sits
at the dog park four or five hours a day
but never in heavy rain and observes
dogs and they're humping behavior and
they're gentle closely observes the
genitals of close to $10,000 yeah
inspecting animals you're very amazing I
am committed
unless it's raining and then interrogate
their owners as to their sexual
orientation but we needed something else
in there you know like choice lines dog
parks are petri dishes for Kay and I
rape cultures but we need something else
and again the trick to this thing is
what's morally fashionable who is the
most depression variables so I thought
well you know a black female
criminologist so they like googled black
female criminology I just looked at
Wikipedia and it was like something I
found someone I'm like okay let's look
at this through a lens of black female
criminology they can't reject it because
they'd be saying that there's something
wrong there be not validating someone's
lived experiences so we looked at the
whole thing through black feminist
criminology boom published so we got
seven of those inner accepted with seven
more the mine comfrey right
yeah wait let's not gloss over that one
okay this is actually incredible what
you did okay well you want to go that
was by far the most difficult of the
paper so you can incredible I guess is
fair because it was really hard we had
like proper internal meltdowns trying to
figure out how to make this work we took
a chapter of mine Kampf Hitler's Auto
ethnography really yes manifesto is an
auto ethnography for the first half yeah
and so we were flipping through a trend
that we thought the original thought
behind that really was I think Helen
suggested it we should take some awful
old thing it wasn't specified that would
be mine comp yet like a theologian just
railing on something or whatever some
famous old tract that's just gross and
then rewrite it as postmodern activist
progressive activism or whatever and so
it naturally led very quickly to mine
comp that's that's the example so I'm
reading through mine comp and then
chapter 11 is the big homerun chapter
it's like that's I think the you know
something railing on the Jews shows up
400 times in Chapter 11 alone and it was
like well that's too extreme can't
actually use that one flip to chapter 12
this is where pillar makes this call for
how are we gonna organize the Nazi Party
and what sacrifices are necessary and
I'm reading through there something oh
my gosh this is it yeah so I copy and
pasted that straight out of off the
internet onto a Word document and I went
through and everywhere it said our
movement the party whatever took that
out stuck in intersectional feminism and
then I started making the sentences make
sense around that and then we went
through and changed all the wording just
a little so it get past plagiarism
yeah and that gave us this kind of
unreadable document that was just a
transliteration of Hitler's chapter 12
about how to be Nazis and then I think
it's incredible didn't we just as in
theory yeah so Helen went through
primarily and was like oh wow this
reminds me she was reading a lot about
choice feminism which is that if a woman
makes her own choices that's feminist
which seems like a pretty reasonable
approach to feminism if you're going to
go with one and so Helen was looking at
how they were criticizing choice
feminism and thought that might be a
good way to go with this so she's like
wow this looks like this this one you
know paper this looks like another one
this will fit here and then I went
through some of the intersectional you
know critical race feminism scholarship
the black feminism scholarship was like
oh wow this sounds like that this sounds
like that we just started weaving in
theory in between pieces of hillier well
we tried to maintain the tone and flavor
that Hillier was putting out so Hitler
lays out a 14-point plan to design the
Nazi Party and we condensed it down to
eight reordered them so that they kind
of made sense in some kind of a
theoretical structure and we sent it off
to feminist theory a journal and we
thought there's no way you know we just
wanted to see what would happen
we had no thinking that this would it
would possibly get in and feminist
theory peer reviewed it they rejected it
but they peer reviewed it and then all
of a sudden that was right when we went
to Portland in February last year and it
was like this is a big deal that they
took it to peer review because we're
gonna get comments so the goal that
paper became get reviewer comments on
the section of my Kampf see when they
say about it when they review it still
assuming they reject it we took those
comments that feminist theory gave us
saying oh it's too liberal you're trying
to universalize feminism and that means
one woman copy
another woman it's too liberal maybe
that's actually that's my business area
isn't it so so then we took those those
comments we modified it a little bit we
massaged it to fit for a Social Work
Journal by working in Social Work stuff
we send it off to a feminist Social Work
Journal and the feminist Social Work
Journal gave us a few more comments you
need to make problem you need to make a
lie ship problematic because if I claim
I'm an ally now I have a power dynamic
with the person I'm allied with so slave
that would be better yeah yeah and so we
did that and we sent it in and back to
him and they accepted it and it was like
probably days away from actually being
published when the Wall Street Journal
broke their story but they accepted this
rewritten chapter of mine confidence
stayed true and the key to that what
really happened with that is that Hitler
was pushing the politics of grievance
Hitler grew to power because he was
pushing politics of grievance Germany
got screwed we're gonna rise back up to
her great Germany blah blah blah
grievance grievance grievance grievance
well we called our stuff that weird hard
in grievance studies because they study
social grievances through not German
identity or national identity but
through personal identity of race gender
sexuality and so on and so the politics
of grievance were very appealing in a
feminist social work Journal that
grievance can go into Social Work and
inform social workers on how to make
feminism more solidified to improve
social work outcomes and that's where it
gets really scary right because that's a
practical field right so okay so before
we get go too far on that let's just
back up for one second and what sort of
lead you to and Helen to decide to do
this in the first place so my audience
is pretty familiar with you but maybe
you want to give a little bit of why why
you why did why is it that you said this
is what we have to do to to sort of
strike this thing at the knees so many
people had recognized what the problem
was the problem being post-modernism the
problem being a corrupt a corruption in
scholarship the problem being that many
disciplines have lost a focus on truth
they thought they already had the truth
so they placed an agenda before the
truth and we're deeply concerned about
speech issues on campus
we're deeply concerned about what the
fact that kids in class couldn't view
alternative opinions and I myself don't
hold those opinions I'm not a
conservative I'm not Christian obviously
but I wanted I want people to have the
opportunity to voice their ideas and
then other people to have the
opportunity to respond to those ideas
and so we took a look at this and we
traced it back to a single body of
scholarship basically anything that has
the name Studies behind it and so what
had happened is that these peoples that
have these folks have taken over the
educational administration and they're
institutionalizing ideas found in this
body of literature and it's absolutely
toxic to us it's poisoning us all and we
wanted to take a look at those canons of
literature which is actually when I
called you yeah yeah you called me that
day and you were like am I crazy am I
going crazy
and I was like probably carry on Pete
yeah yeah please go on
and so he said he said you know I've
been looking at to give a little more
context actually we were before I get to
that we were in we were in looking at
social media and a lot of the people
that are trying to have mostly on the
left are trying to you know centrist
liberals are trying to have honest
conversations about issues about race
sexuality and so on and what happens
boom racist sexist sam harris is kensey
blasted for being a sexist over some
comment he made I know a little bit
about this yeah a little bit do you
and getting blasted for being a racist
because of the Islamophobia thing and
that grows a racist moment with Ben
Affleck you know that all this stuff was
going on we're like what's going on you
try to have conversations you know with
like Sam Harris is a reasonable guy he's
an honest broker what's happening and we
start getting called racists for talking
about it and then every time it comes
back to this well racism doesn't mean
what the dictionary says racism doesn't
mean what you think it means only white
people can be racist only men can be
sexist and it has to have structural
power behind it and all this stuff and
we're like that's a peculiar definition
and maybe okay system system
racism's a thing it's real okay fine but
that's not the whole story here you know
you're using a particular term you're
meaning a particular term by a very
general term race is always a systemic
racism is real what do you mean by what
I'm eating is that certainly there there
are structural forces that we have for
decades or centuries possibly at least
in the United States disenfranchise
certain individuals we we there was
going way back we have slavery we come
out of slavery and then there were
segregation and there were Jim Crow laws
and we come out of that and there is you
know systematically screwing over you
know the housing markets in certain
cities Chicago was particularly bad for
that so there was this kind of
ghettoization of it and there's all
kinds of stuff like that had have
created a
think that these scholars are correct to
say if there's something of an unlevel
playing field going on there have been
great improvements however there are
still some issues there are still some
some concerns there's you know they do
these studies or they put out things and
they put a white sounding name or a
black sounding name and then it doesn't
come out clean there's a bias there
right so this just for the record I mean
this is where I would get where I've
gotten into that moment with Larry elder
that you mentioned before I don't know I
personally wouldn't call that systemic
anymore I don't think it's in the system
anymore that may be individual death
will act in a racist way or in a sexist
way right so that doesn't mean there
isn't historical writing smashes so I
don't think that there I don't think
that there is a institutional thing yeah
whether it comes down I don't know
whether there are issues say within the
police or whatever that may be there are
lots of racist cops and maybe there
aren't I don't know but that whether
it's codified or not I don't think that
that problem where it's not codified
anymore right yeah yeah and there's a
historical hangovers and etc there's a
lot to it but sure I can accept the idea
like let's just run with the idea that
this whole structural racism thing is a
thing well when you say racism but you
mean structural racism you're cheating
you'reyou're saying one word that means
something to almost everybody but you
mean something really narrow and
specific but we see this was with you
know racism we saw it with sexism see it
with diversity you see it with inclusion
you see it with equity you see word
after word after word and this is how we
traced back to the literature it's like
where are the
kind of oddball definitions coming from
Oh at the time we thought sociology and
so this is where Pete calls me when it
we'd started looking at this literature
he calls me is like am I crazy am I
losing it I look at this scholarship now
I was just talking to somebody about it
and they didn't get it so help me out
here
I look at this scholarship in it it's
like this Gender Studies scholarship
plays the exact same role for gender
scholars that the Bible place for
Christians at the Quran plays room for
Muslims is that what's going on here and
I would I had just written this book or
was in the process I don't remember
exactly the date I'd written this book
trying to look at the psychological
motivations behind belief in God and
what people mean by that and I was like
actually I think you are exactly on it
you know because the the idea of God
represents things like morality and
purpose and community and various things
to different people
and here you have they all you know
religions all have scriptures or nearly
all have scriptures I think you actually
do have the same thing here you have
this special revelation going on where
people are able to put down their
opinions and somehow it gets legitimized
through a moral process in religion it's
you know a holiness you're holy enough
you put down your opinion you're a
Gustin you put down your confessions and
now it becomes sacred writ and in this
case it's through this kind of weakness
in the in the progressive moral
architecture that allows for people
never want to be even not just do they
not want to be racists they want to be
considered racist they want to be
accidentally secret considered racist
they want to be complicit in racism and
there's in this whole thing to where
this is such a huge taboo they're so
afraid to become racist that they've let
this stuff pass to where people can
write theoretical prejudices and
opinions in as if they are scholarship
and then it gets validated and published
in the peer-reviewed literature now
there's a study that says right what are
they point to that they point to the
study and they say so that's they don't
need faith they had a point to this this
is how we know and your for guests and
our friend Brett Ornstein calls it ID
launder it yeah they have an idea they
have a moral impulse they want to
discharge that they write in their day
have these make-believe journals and
they publish it and then they start
teaching it to folks and then that's how
it spreads it's like a contagion
Yeah right yeah we couldn't have the
conversation right because that's what
they would do because you try to have a
conversation they say this thing and you
say well how do you know that and
they're like this then they point to the
scholarship and Pete's idea was that's
the same as when a when a Christian is
you know ranting about fire and
brimstone and you're like how do you
know that this and they point to
Deuteronomy or whatever you know and
it's the same concept and so then you
can't what do you do how do you argue
well the only thing you can do is say
well maybe that scholarships
questionable and then that conversation
was impossible right because if you
question the scholarship you're racist
so we said well let's look at the
scholarship yeah you were piecing this
together for a long time because I quote
you every other week on this show when
you started calling this postmodern
movement a secular religion it's a
secular religion and we've been talking
about that for years and then all of a
sudden all all you know I see Andrew
Sullivan I some water I saw all these
people talking about it I'm not saying
you know we're first or the hipsters of
the sector yeah well you were the first
person that I heard talk about it was so
obvious because we came from this from
the New Atheists uh-huh and the
parallels was striking and just on that
I think Mike Nana has a video on that
that we tweeted in which you can see you
can literally see the canoe story that
happened to Brett and Heather yeah and
it's what's it
Mike Nate is YouTube channel yeah as
YouTube you know my rules are there
they're not just conspicuous there you
can't ignore them yeah it's impossible
to watch this little documentary he's
done on evergreen just recently so yeah
for your viewers that don't know yeah
Mike Dana is actually a documentary
filmmaker who came in he was looking at
the same kinds of problems going on in
Australia getting curious about it that
ended up by chance leading to us
crossing paths we told him about what we
were doing last fall 2017 and he was
like okay I'll document it as long as
I'm allowed to tell the truth about
everything really yeah that's what we
want to do anyway so we have a
documentary filmmaker there's been
following us around tracking what we've
been doing and because the problem so
complicated he slowly you know the Helen
and Peter and I get all this like we did
this project and we wrote these papers
we've actually kind of had the secret
secret fourth member who is this
filmmaker who has he learned more and
more about it
kind of an integral contributor to our
thinking and our ideas and how to
communicate it and so he's now working
on a documentary a feature-length
documentary about us and the work we did
but he also was running a YouTube
channel with shorts about either us what
we're doing and he just released this
our almost hour-long documentary first
half of a longer piece on Evergreen
that's like Netflix quality I mean it's
for real you really do want to check it
out on his youtube channel and it is
impossible I would say to watch that and
not seeing holy craps this is a religion
and this is how it operates and this
isn't just a religion this is a party
for didn't know sorry good well so as
the guy who wrote a manual for creating
atheist deprogramming religious thinking
is something you've been interested in a
long time so did you view this as the
first blow to enable that process to
start happening I do I I think that
they're they're canons the way they come
to knowledge the method that they rely
on is at the very least a reasonable
person or barring Walter Kaufman's
definition every reasonable person would
would have to look at that and say wait
a second they've generated these
self-contained ecosystems that anyone
looking at it from the outside would
realize but I do think that that one of
the things this project showed was that
those cannons are now dealers in amost
there's no reason a serious person would
take a look at that and say you know
because you had asked before your
initial question like what are the
papers where do the journals you know we
published a piece and Hypatia
in in which that piece said there was
the joke's on you and it was criticizing
us for the conceptual penis but it was
very meta paper because the joke was
actually on them for publishing the
paper right so I think that a reasonable
person who would look at this would say
wow there's something going on here but
look at the reaction to this it's
interesting and it's like yes I wrote a
manual for creating atheist and what's
the next what what would a reasonable
person say a reasonable person say wow I
know that sexism is wrong I know that
racism is wrong I know that these forms
of discrimination or wrong and we want
to study them right and these folks
pointed out
a very serious flame in the literature
and I want to maintain my intellectual
and scholarly integrity and we're gonna
try to fix those problems yes but they
have not done that they have done
instead is exactly what he predicted and
we wrote about in the arial piece which
was instead of taking a look at how they
produce knowledge they they now
scrutinize the authors who submit so
they google so they make sure that the
authors are legit so instead of being a
sincere Enquirer again they think they
already have truth exactly like a
fundamentalist well so we've seen so
many examples of this I mean I would say
this is where they could have taken a
look in the mirror after Trump got
elected they could have taken a look in
the mirror after saying you can
everyone's a Nazi and then I can punch
Nazis and we the list goes on and on of
when there could have been a moment of
reflection we've never seen it so I know
when we spoke a few days before the The
Wall Street Journal piece one huh and we
were talking about well maybe there's a
chance this will wake some of them up
and I said you I was like no of course
not I mean there's there's nothing that
that can be done so then in the face of
that if you agree with the premise then
what can be done other than we can you
can keep doing this and we can keep
talking about it we can keep waking
other people up but for the people that
are in that cult which I actually think
is inappropriate I joined for it and
then what do you do you have to do what
you always have to do which is you have
to find ways which means you have to
find legitimate ways and effective ways
and not authoritarian ways to curtail
their influence if they are unwilling to
wake up or change their mind or
reconsider then that's fine and within a
liberal society everybody is allowed to
follow their conscience they're allowed
to add that's that's the principle of
freedom of religion right as you're
allowed to worship as you will so if you
want to worship the woke god of social
justice whatever I suspect though they
would not afford that freedom if they
were really in charge well you know
those of us that maybe don't believe in
this sure you don't see it from hardcore
religionists either they would they
wouldn't afford the freedom if they got
the power either theologians or
theocrats are just as scary so if you
want to if you want to curtail their
power
the answer is always in secularism and
it does have to come from other people
so within their different audiences here
right so there's everyday people and
they should they you know really think
twice before they enroll what if it's a
kid going to college before they enroll
in a Gender Studies program yeah
probably should somebody be stepping up
in the advisory sector of the Academy
and saying you know I think you have a
lot of talent say it's a young black
student a lot of talent you could go to
graduate school you could study and
instead of saying there's this
opportunity for you to study this niche
thing about lived black experience and
writing in Auto ethnography and get your
guaranteed PhD cuz nobody's allowed to
say you're wrong maybe you could go into
some field it doesn't have to be you
know everybody always goes to stem maybe
it's engineering order doesn't have to
be that could be anything be a historian
be an economist be a political scientist
go in and study something more rigorous
that enhances your critical thinking in
your dialectic process so that would be
advisors could do that right
administrators though but is the flaw is
the flaw of that although I think you're
right at some level is the flaw there
that because they're viewing this as a
religion there's almost no way to show
them that the people before them had any
knowledge of how the world works like
they really want to erase everything
about the past yeah I think ultimately
there's the battleground is to get
people to realize that that's
unacceptable so a good metaphor for that
is I don't want to alienate any or you
if you ever been driving I know this is
a dated example now with like cool
futuristic radio and podcasts and things
but you drive in you're on a road trip
you're in a different you know region
you're dazzling the dial on the radio
and you're like I can't find anything
good to listen to and you flip things
like country and yeah and you flip the
thing and it's something else it's talk
you don't listen to that you flip the
thing ah some rock song comes on you're
kind of like getting into it your role
and you know you hit the accelerator a
little bit and then they're like Jesus
is my light and you're like I know what
this is you change the dial again right
away because you hear that and you
didn't want to get proselytized too you
wanted to listen to you know some some
Metallica or something so you didn't
want to hear that you thought you're
into something and it's the wrong thing
and so that that feeling you get though
when you hear the religious thing that
you didn't know was religious and it
just hooked you all of a sudden end of
religion that's the react
and the people should have they hear
this woke stuff check your priveledge I
know what this is
I'm not going along with that and if
they want to point to something they
want to point to some hard evidence
these guys B'gosh and lindsey pork
roasts they did this thing and maybe we
didn't I mean Pete says I like the
nuance a little further than Pete did
about delegitimizing their cannon I
think that there's probably some
legitimate work going on but who can
tell what it is how do you know if I can
make up stuff and Pete can make up stuff
and Helen can make up stuff and we can
just massage the literature to let it be
how do you know when it's the real thing
and when it's not so what we need is to
clean that up and get you could get to
the bottom of when the work is using
good rigorous methods and when it's not
and review all this stuff so so I know
you guys obviously got support out of
the quarters that I would have expected
you to get supportive so Jordan Peterson
and Jonathan hate and even Pinker and
then it and all these guys okay that's
not to be surprised because these guys
have been talking about these things did
you get anything did you get any support
though out of did you get anything out
of say more lefty professors that you
didn't really think we're gonna in
whispers in whispers yeah yeah and this
is again the conservatory with all the
loss of it so I find when I get emails
from that type of person that says Oh
Dave you know you're doing the right
thing here you're calling out the
nonsense of the left and I just can't do
it because I'm at a university or I have
a job like I actually am starting to
hate those people I mean that sort of
slightly it's organic it's not the right
word but I'm really I'm really I've had
it with those people I'm not a superhero
I'm just doing what I think is right
what is your feeling about that set of
people at the University I think that we
need to be more this because I don't
mean this is on any other way but we
need to be more compassionate for them
some people they don't have the they're
just cowards and it's not their fault
they're just live in a state of timidity
or fear and they don't want to lose
their job or maybe they prioritize
employment and their families and
whatever it is over the truth and that
that's the life they lead yeah if you're
in a system where the system itself does
not take kindly to this and I think
academics have a lot of sunk cost going
on into their their careers you
we'll have a lot of great options if you
bail from the Academy you've spent
decades getting where you are it had to
be a passion to get Larry so it's like I
want to say it there with you by the way
the one of the first people who talked
to me in whispers after we came public
was a friend of mine with multiple phd's
big-time academic guy and he came up and
he was so excited he was even talking
low even though we were alone and yeah
it's like you know whispering almost to
me literally even though we were just
the two of us and he said you know I'm
so thrilled what you did it's needed to
happen blah blah blah the Academy needs
to change and he's reformed please don't
tell anybody I said this and my reaction
and I'm a very very calm patient person
for people who don't know me I I don't
think I get mad maybe once a year if
that over anything and maybe I need to I
don't know but different showed if I
became yeah mad at him like immediately
my reaction was you coward but yeah then
I thought about how much he's invested
and so I think Pete's right compassion
is necessary for the silent professors
but what we need also is for those who
are courageous enough to open their
mouths right the more people who say
look at like old communist thing or the
communist regime has fallen but
everybody's kind of going along with it
and everybody knows if they're the first
person to step out that they're gonna
get shot or dragged off or whatever and
it's gonna silence everybody else but if
everybody at once in the town or the
city or whatever all said you know
communism [ __ ] they couldn't do
anything about it right to men but are
you guys then but you're sort of saying
both things at the same time I mean I
get it like let's be compassionate
towards people and I get it people have
other considerations and careers and
families and other things that I'm not
denying any of that but you guys aren't
superheroes I'm not okay I need to speak
up and I'm incredibly grateful for the
people who have spoken up and has anyone
not survived I mean I think this is the
other thing that we have to push as
anyone that spoke up about these things
that's spoken up yes people have lost
their jobs yes and and you know James
demora Google and Lindsey Shepard
execute but no one's been executed if
anything these people are all stronger
at some level so yeah I agree with that
actually yeah so so that to me that's
where we have to go it I'm I'm really
incredibly grateful for the people
who've spoken up and I'm telling my
email box has been flooded with letters
of supports
people they don't know people all over
the world and I'm incredibly grateful
for that and what we are seeing is more
and more people are putting their names
on this that's the big change our big
change we're seeing that people in
biology for example that's what gives me
hope for this whole thing and so I have
only two colleagues who have publicly
come out and said that they have support
me out of the whole University and you
know the Portland State University
Vanguard published this crazy smear hit
piece on me with a huge nose as a
filming villain yeah they spelled his
name wrong they said hell had them seven
of these eleven ten with PhDs couldn't
even spell two of the three names yeah
and it was a it was anonymous the people
who designed it was all it was students
and faculty if they had the truth on
their side and they were so right and
you were so evil well you could at least
put your name on oh that is a big thing
to write that's all yeah well that's
also the part of it is that and the
James Moore event when it was just James
for myself as hosted once a university
we email the Women's Studies department
and with James or myself and we said
come on stage and let's let's have a it
wasn't a debate a spirited conversation
got two rejections and nothing else
two days later February 19th James
Lindsay Hill employs myself the first
thing I said at the James to more events
please women's anyone with a PhD and you
don't want to punch down right anyone
who's qualified as phd's published and
Sarah please come up we'll give you a
seat on stage you can talk right beside
us and we'll have a spirited
conversation nothing nothing and then at
myth car later on the organizers trying
to find so they said they totally they
spend 80 hours trying to find a
qualified person someone in the field of
Gender Studies no one would go on with
James Lindsay and Clay Rutledge and
myself but is this the brilliance of
what they've done and I mean that
obviously slightly tongue-in-cheek which
is you label everyone a racist and ROTC
and everything and then you say well
these people don't deserve platforms so
either they won't give you the platform
in the first place or if they've given
you the platform well they already have
their out which is I don't sit on
platforms with not why's that so thus
they've created this engine that that
gives them the ultimate escape and gives
you new operate no opportunity to defend
your ideas to them and one crucial piece
to
which is one of the differences between
traditional religions Christianity in
particular is that they they don't value
discourse in dialogue it's just not part
of their Canon in fact if anything it's
viewed as a form of violence and so when
you have folks who in not only they
don't value it they're already winning
the culture war right I know that might
be a controversial statement but but
certainly they're winning the culture
war in the Academy yeah
no I think we're making some gains now
yeah and I think that can be metrics are
like how many people are putting their
names when they come out on these
letters or when they're speaking
publicly about it but why would you have
a conversation or a debate with someone
if you know you're already winning it's
like the presidential debate you want to
have more if you're losing it fewer if
you're winning and so I think that's
also operative so this is where it gets
a bit deep if you want why does that
happen
I mean obviously you can look at it and
just it's a brilliant strategy in a
sense but their literature again like I
said earlier they're terrified of
complicity right they're going to be
complicit in something so sharing the
stage with somebody with abhorrent views
equals complicity and also giving them a
platform but it's really difficult to
understand that for for people outside
of this kind of and we call applied
postmodern it changed in the 90s it's
not the same as Foucault and Derry done
and all this nonsense deconstruction
stuff it's a bit more focused it's
really it's its identity activism if
you're outside of that view it's very
difficult to understand how this all
works they why do they see something
like conversation or dialogue as
violence and the reason is that they see
that everything is is has identity and
in they see identity as an ideology as
ideology connected to identity baek's
that ideology into whatever it produces
so you and I are in peat or three white
guys sitting here and we're saying we
should have conversation we should have
conversation and their answer is well of
course you should say you have
conversation white people baked up the
idea of having conversation to get to
idea so that you can maintain their
power exactly so it's got this huge
nasty conspiracy theory element that
comes down to the very
roots of what we would call applied
post-modernism which is that privilege
and power exists to perpetuate and
legitimize themselves if you don't
understand that that's how they view the
world it looks like they're playing this
very dirty game but they actually really
think that this is something that we did
it's different by the way from Sokol the
so called wrote the pastiche we started
with these hoaxes the first six papers
we wrote the ones that just died because
if you remember what he said 20 and then
we talked about 14 of them seven
accepted seven more in play we started
with hoaxes and we couldn't get hoaxes
in we couldn't replicate so calls could
and we think the reason is either it
could be our skill but it could also be
that something changed and we think that
something fundamentally changed in the
late 80s and early 90s and under
kimberlé crenshaw is critical race
theory and intersectionality she
literally says that we need to apply
post-modernism and mapping the margins
is that that's the paper that the first
mention of that section yes that is the
birthplace of intersectionality and she
says that we can't achieve things if all
we do is deconstruct so we need to admit
that some things are real identities
real and oppression based on identity or
real and we need to use postmodern
methods apply post modern methods of
deconstruction to achieve things through
those assumptions so it's a big turn so
they literally see that privilege and
power exists to maintain themselves
legitimize themselves and so there's
this whole kind of weird conspiracy
theory element to it from their
perspective that oh you want to use
reason because reason was invented by
Western values that want to perpetuate
themselves and dominate the world and
you want to use science and evidence
because same reason and you want to have
conversation for the same reason and
then when you start hanging it's
incredible it's it's unbelievably
profound it's it's like the very thing
that got you into the into the cognitive
sinkhole in the first place the thing
that can emancipate you from that you
deny access just like Boko Haram what is
an indication forbidden right the one
thing that these folks need is Western
education right so the very thing that
caused the problem in the first place
they avoid they won't take because it
will liberate them from the thing that
causes the problem yeah yeah so that's
what we set out to do though is to
understand when our hoax has failed we
set out to understand them on their own
terms they call this being an outsider
within
and it was actually huge like in lesbian
research early on and Louis lesbian
social researchers because you go into
female oriented spaces or whatever and
they don't quite fit so they're an
outsider but they're inside and then
they document it and that's one of their
kind of methodology save her so we
became that Outsiders within their thing
and we wanted to actually understand the
way that they think and so now we sit in
this odd position where you know I have
one foot in applied postmodern theology
if you will and I have one foot in
reality and I I can now see the world
both ways and that's kind of like the
thing that sets us apart from Sokol it's
the thing that we have to offer that's
very different because we understand
where they're coming from why they're
coming from that place and how their
logic and and their approach is broken
or damaging or unethical or whatever
happens to be in the case so you
mentioned sort of high level ways we can
break them at us I mean one one simple I
found a couple simple ones as I've
talked to kids at schools one is you
know you'll say to that they'll say that
they're for Islam and they're for gay
people and then you'll say well can any
gay person is there any gay MA is there
a mosque in America or anywhere in the
West for that matter or anywhere in the
East or anywhere that will have gay
marriage and the answer is no there
there might maybe be one discredited one
somewhere apparently but so it's like
how can we be for both of these things
this this actually doesn't make sense
and that sort of little bomb in their
brain does set off something I find you
know but like so you need little tricks
like that so the best thing which then
they'll tell you you're an Islamophobe
anyway or something but I found that
actually asking people how the dog park
paper the dog humping paper got honored
and then explained what the paper says
yeah how did this paper get honored as
exemplary scholarship and feminist
geography I watched kind of like the
eyes on focus and come back here right
but you need them to understand a
certain amount of what you've done right
yeah what about wait a minute I'm for
Islam and for gays but if no gay can get
married at a mosque well now it seems
like something sort of more obvious
something like that one of the things I
just wrote about this last year in
skeptic magazine one of the things that
I've learned from over a quarter century
of critical thinking is instead of
asking people what is your evidence for
that
which is totally reasonable in question
I switched to what's called a de
feasibility question or a dis
confirmation question I front-load this
in all of my my conversations now and
it's basically a simple question how
could that belief be false so someone
tells you something and you say well how
could how I'm not saying you are wrong
about that just how could that be false
even asking that question opens up
spaces you know enables people to
process things in a way in which they
they ordinarily wouldn't it's an
incredibly effective question yeah so
what tangible evidence is there that
that this thing is starting to succeed
beyond that we you know there was some
cover given by some some big names there
was some good press not all the press
was good plenty of plenty of places when
after you guys do I mean do is there
more credible evidence then what do they
go after though they went after our
motivation yeah it was a lot about your
motivations in particular and you know
mr. controversial formula your beliefs
in the basis of evidence huge
controversy so what the question is what
can be done
well is there tangibly evidence that
we're turning yeah I think first of all
we've had probably 10 to 1 support to
detraction so people writing these
negative pieces yeah they're out there
but I think it's ten to one support and
I keep hearing I know it's mostly
whispered but as Pete said some people
are starting to put their names to it a
lot of people did in his support at
Portland State I'm hearing a lot of
people say things like you got them and
they know you've got alright hmm you got
them and they know you've got them
that's that's powerful these are people
in humanities departments that are
telling of course I can't say who they
are but they're saying they know you've
got him and then the but we expected you
know the tornado to come after us and
then there was no tornado right it was
just kind of this rolling over thing and
then eventually it's nasty hit piece and
Pete's student newspapers right there's
nothing and that's my point is that
people survive the monster and I want
people to understand that is it's so
many people and now people are starting
to put that the toe out or stick their
head out a little bit they're writing
things are putting their name on it
there's a thing I get it emails yeah all
the time
hey you know you emboldened me to speak
off to my class and like I mentioned
some of these papers I've mentioned this
so we see a groundswell of people
willing to question and chow
the names a huge thing but people come
out I now have all these organizations
that have endorsed me against you know
the possible termination for my offenses
yeah so let's just jump there for just a
sec because this is not as if it hasn't
had a professional cost for you guys but
for you in particular and I know you
don't want to play the victim but can
you just explain what the hell is going
on over at Portland State right now so
they charged me there are two charges
one is not going to the IRB human
subjects and they considered the
researchers human some that they excuse
me the journal editors human subjects I
found guilty on that and it's escalated
to wait can you explain that a little
bit yes so there are these things called
IRB s and any time you experiment on
people if they're originally from
Tuskegee and medical experiments you
need to get permission from this board
and tell them exactly what you're going
to do so that they know that the
subjects upon whom you're doing whatever
in in intervention are gonna be fine so
I was found guilty of not going to that
those are public documents that can be
revealed when I received it and then
that that has escalated to the provost
and the president the University and
they can make a decision about
punishments I was also told that I have
to take a training and there's I can't
do any I might I can't be a primary
research or research or any and anything
until this has been adjudicated then
it's then it's the other charges
fabrication of data these are very
serious for the fabrication of data in
particular and the idea behind that is
that you don't want the research stream
to be contaminated right so we can't
have people putting making stuff up
basically publishing it and then what
why people do that the motivation is to
advance their own careers to get grants
to you know publish and get tenure or
what-have-you
even though that's not obviously not
what you guys were doing you weren't
falsifying data to sell off a paper that
was going to make you look like a rock
star to get another position you were
actually trying to help the institutions
that well
there's a we can talk about the
motivations but Trust has been eroded in
our public institution this trust has
been around in the Academy and it's a
huge problem and but we can talk about
that so that invests in investigation is
ongoing and so again but the my union
rep informed me of my lawyers that the
punishment for that can be termination
so I'm I'm now kind of caught in limbo
and I honestly do not know what's gonna
happen
are you in any hot water beyond the no
I'm not I'm out of the Academy so I
don't have a I have no institutional
review board over me and I have I have
nobody coming down on me I mean I did
basically have to stop working my job
for almost two years to do this so I'm
semi borderline unemployed and it's kind
of you know I don't think I'm getting
into academia again so I'm not hot water
but that's sort of the huge irony of
this right so pizza and hot water but
why because he's in in an institution
I'm free to do this and then there's
nobody who can come down on me but Pete
is under you know possibly losing his
job and all of this you know
professional misconduct stuff this seems
like it has technicality written all
over it it's like oh you happen to be
there in the wrong position now I
understand that these boards are
important and what they do and the
investigation needs to be be had but at
the same time it does have technicality
written all over it is there some weird
how is it that the this is ethical if I
do it but unethical if he does it by by
virtue of the fact that he has an
academic position that should credential
him higher than that I'm credentialed it
doesn't it doesn't seem to really make
any sense so for me I've not really had
any hot water I also live in the
southeast which helps quite a bit
because as I was walking around you know
I'm here in Southern California so I'm
walking around in Hollywood last night
we go out and somebody's like that guy's
one of us and I was like everybody where
I'm from one of us what are you talking
about I don't understand everybody
agrees with me about I mean they don't
agree with my politics necessarily I do
firmly plant myself on the left but at
the same time I they certainly agree
with me about gender studies they
certainly agree with they even go
further than I would go I think gender
studies is important for example I think
we should be studying gender
in a multidisciplinary way I just think
it should have to follow you know the
lines of evidence that should have to
admit when it's wrong right yeah race is
a huge issue look how explosive it is
for example for the last several years
it's been only the most explosive social
topic how are you gonna do it if you're
not doing it rigorously do you think
though it's possible that that race
let's say is the most explosive yes so
topic because we have created what they
have sown that when you when you
increase people's awareness of race or
gender or identity you make it touchier
you make it a bigger deal you make
people look for reasons to dig into it
and you do explode the issue because if
everything being equal if you asked me I
mean I've been saying this a little bit
more and I don't get any great joy in
saying it but if you ask me where the
real racism is coming from right now
it's coming from them it's again this I
mean I say this all the time and
everyone knows is theirs yes are there a
couple KKK members are there a couple
white supremacists yesterday of any
institutional power no does anyone with
any academic power or anything think
that they're good no but but this thing
has power behind it so so that's why I
fear it much more used racism racism in
conservative circles coming from the
southeast and having lived there for
almost 40 years has definitely changed
dramatically in my life yeah the
attitudes are very very different
I honestly it's it's a whole separate
show or whatever because the South has a
complicated relationship with race and
racism and it's not simple and there's a
lot of issues but there are also a lot
of improvements but certainly you don't
see the kind of institutional racism
that we used to there's some weird stuff
around immigration and whether that
touches into it or not because it's also
got seriously legitimate things that
need to be heard and discussed that the
left progressive left because I don't
want to lump the whole left into the
progressive left refuses to have those
conversations honestly you know when you
dump 1.8 million people into a culture
all of a sudden would they have a
totally different culture things happen
when they you know there's there's real
issues around immigration and I really
wish we could have grown up
conversations about it instead of oh
it's 100 percent open borders versus a
hundred percent right you know
build a wall or whatever the hell it is
and so I wish we could have a real
conversation there and part of the
reason we can't is because one side is
like it's racist to have the
conversation so I do actually generally
agree with you that the the crusade to
make race more salient which is almost
directly out of critical race theory and
the crusade to make gender identity more
salient which was almost straight out of
gender theory we can go on right down
below sexuality theory fat studies well
we write down the list of every identity
category you can imagine the
intersectional matrix of dominance that
increases everybody's touchiness
everybody's willingness to be offended
and everybody's everybody who can
manipulate their offense to their own
advantage their ability and willingness
maybe to take that advantage where it's
their right well that's why I believe it
is the most dangerous set of ideas out
there I believe that this set of ideas
the way you just laid it out is far more
dangerous than anything I'm seeing out
of what Trump saying and again is
someone that didn't even vote for Trump
I would say that that is what is going
to turn neighbor against neighbor you
will look at your neighbor and judge
them by the color of their skin and what
they should get for that or because
they're overweight or because they're a
woman or because they're gay I mean that
is what it's the it's the complete
ripping of the fabric of everything that
America is yeah or the idea I have to
Paul I mean I certainly agree with that
I have to pause on the Trump thing I
fear me too I've been on a Trump diet i
I just I so can't stand we almost did an
hour without saying Trump I was I know I
know
yeah and you know what I don't need to
mean to make it either or but this but
there's no question about it that this
is a toxin and it's contagious and it's
destroying our societies and again it's
coming from one place and if people want
to know why should they care about about
a bunch of kooky academics it's because
this stuff spills out into the real
world and it spills out consistently and
we've now trained an entire generation
of people both to be brittle when they
hear something to be offended like that
if you have a belief that's uh neva
densed or if you're a intensely
ideological person then you have to do
something to make up the slack when
someone contradicts you when you're
faced with an alternative an idea you
can lie you can be offended we can walk
away you can scream it
people call them a racist but you can't
engage their ideas and now we've taught
and I'm deeply concerned about this
because we've taught an entire
generation of kids to to not do that
what we should be doing is to not teach
them how to suspend their judgments but
to make better more discerning judgment
particularly as that spills into the
moral sphere so how worried are you then
when this really seeps into the
political system I'm really worried it
seemed to me that that's the horizon
horizon right now if you look where all
the energy is yeah it's behind the set
of young democratic socialists perfect
leave all of this so that's why I'm or
that's why I think it's so perfect I
personally feel like Trump is borderline
an unmitigated disaster now we've done
really well our institutions have been
strong so I get worried about anybody
wants to tear down institutions given
that they are a check or if he's if he's
an out-of-control executive that the
institutional thing itself is what
controls the out-of-control executive
that's the point of limiting executive
power is that the institution is broader
and you don't put it all in a tyrant or
whatever if that comes along I don't
know that he's a tyrant he's whatever
but I think let's say that I think and
it's not perfectly true that he's the
the most dangerous thing that's
happening in the world right now I
actually and this is you want your
controversy to see if I can top Pete
from yeah come on give me something here
Trump is a result of the regressive left
I think that he got away because he
stood up and he would you know all these
these skulls for years and years and
years you can't say that you can't think
that you can't say that in Trump would
just say it and so who who's watching
this you have this entire group of
people who are sick I live in the south
I talked to him all the time I know
these people these are good decent
people
they're know most of time no fan of
Trump in general they don't like what
he's doing politically and yet they're
like he doesn't care that those people
said you can't say that he said it
anyway he does they you know you can't
say such-and-such about this group Trump
says it they think wow here's this kind
of like avatar of me being able to you
know somebody else who can take the fall
for it take the heat for because if I
say it I'm gonna get blasted he says
that he doesn't get in trouble that
appealed to a lot of people and then you
have
an election that was a very narrow
margin you don't need a lot of people to
have flipped a margin so I think the
reason we got Trump was very
significantly to do with the fact this
stuff especially in 2015 decided to blow
up to like the only thing you can talk
about check your priveledge Hector
privilege everything and I'm afraid
we're gonna get it again mm-hmm and the
reason I'm afraid especially is maybe
you do maybe don't know this I just
recently found out that they're going to
let trans athletes compete in the Summer
Games in 2020 right before the election
I actually haven't heard that yeah so
they're going to let the transacts
compete as women in the in the 2020
games and that's going to happen
literally a couple months before the
next election the trans bathroom thing
was a giant wedge issue who drummed it
up as a wedge issue I don't know but
that's a whole like that's a fracture
point in society right now in the it is
one because the gender theory doesn't
play out to where anybody can understand
what's going on and it feels like
they're being told how they have to
think on issues and so then you finally
have somebody who comes along you see
something that's outrageous whether it's
the bathrooms every when you start
having like a trans wrestler that like
slam some woman other great bro code jaw
and it's just horrifying there's
something off here and everybody can see
it so I really think that these again
these gender issues race issues these
stupid culture war issues are gonna
possibly prove decisive so anybody who's
who's out there that thinks to Trump is
an unmitigated disaster has to pay
attention to the fact of how the
audience that votes for him thinks about
this social justice crap and what it's
doing it for the slice so I mentioned
this when I had Peterson in Shapiro on
but you know weird way is this where
let's say three guys I can't consider
myself part of the left anymore but I
know you do and I think you do but I
still consider myself a liberal with it
okay bye sure but is this where we
should all be looking in the mirror and
going man this is actually the failure
of the Liberals that when when this
monster was reconstituting itself in the
name of progressivism but all the
Liberals just kind of jumped on board
and knew something was kind of off like
where are the Liberals yeah
where I mean I get it we can name 20
people okay great yeah I'm not a big fan
of blame at this point yeah I just want
to fix well it'd be too mean if we want
to fix it
we have to figure out where our fault
points were right that well if we want
to fix it we have to say what's the best
step forward and to your comment that
you just made I don't think that the
solution to this is to elect people to
office who are steeped in identity based
politics I think that's completely agree
with that that's a reaction to so this
is what I see it - yeah an escalating
series of reactions as well what's
happened and what was that recent study
it was I think they wrote about it in
the Atlantic there was that for seven
political tribes right eight percent are
social justice people some comparable
percent are in two factions are
far-right that's right people and then
you have this gigantic swath in the
middle who are and the key word was
politically exhausted so where are the
Liberals they're putting their head down
and they're being quiet because those
lunatic fringes are doing whether it's
classical liberals center or right or
even dipping into the left because it
works that way whether it's left
liberals but you know true liberals are
the people who need to rise up and say
hey look know our society is a liberal
society we're gonna we're gonna make
sure it stays that way in the rest it's
politics you know how we're gonna sort
out these issues is politics but we have
to get your place working at politics
again where these lunatic fringes don't
want to have it but I had this idea a
couple of years ago that what we're
seeing is and I think this is what's
triggered the problem and and liberals
are just sick of getting yelled at and
they're tired and it's exhausting it's
constant fighting it's constant war most
people don't want to fight but you have
these two sides and each one is able to
convince the people closer to it that
the other side is an existential threat
so every time my wedge issue comes up
every person that sees themselves on the
Left sides with whatever that furthest
faction is when it comes down to it's
got to be this or it's got to be that
because they're so afraid that if the
Conservatives get power you know gays
aren't gonna be able to get married
they're gonna overturn Roe versus Wade
everybody's gonna have and coathanger
abortions or something the next thing
you know climate change is gonna ruin
the planet then the people on the
conservative side see the same thing if
the Liberals get
our if those Democrats get power we're
gonna have open borders Muslims are
gonna be flooding and rapists from
Mexico it's gonna be this whole thing
and they freaked out and it's a nexus
they feel existential threat if the
other side gets power and what that's
done has been this ratcheting up of
tension so the people in the middle get
exhausted and they only make a choice
when they feel forced to make a choice
and then they they don't choose to be
with that extremist group right they
choose not to be with those and they
take take a they take a very broad
stroke side what's the solution to this
shut up extremists we're going down the
middle in that exact right so it's
somebody comes out with an extremist
thing and it's that same thing I said
earlier I know what that is no we're not
doing that I think one of the most
important things and this isn't our
forthcoming book about how to have
impossible conversations Peter and I
just finished one of those important
things is to learn to disavow the
extremists on your side so if you see
yourself on the left say you know those
guys they don't represent me way off to
the left I think I'm on the left but I
distinguish myself from them and learn
how to articulate that and then the left
can clean up its site you can get that
main body of people on the left speaking
out saying those that 80% don't
represent us here's what we really
believe and on the right the same thing
if you're on the right you say you know
what fine I'm on the right good those
dudes way over there these guys that
want to dissolve the government and
drown in the bathtub used to be the
saying right
shrink it to the sides you can drown in
a bathtub they don't represent me okay
that goes too far we need a society that
functions that goes too far I have
conservative values I have this I have
that but that goes too far and if you
then the right can start cleaning itself
because right now if the left tries to
insist the right cleanup the right can't
hear it because it's existential policy
interesting to me because I agree with
you obviously on the left part that the
left the liberals need to do that but to
me the right basically is doing that
they're fighting constantly about these
things because you've got healthy
branches of Trump people and never Trump
or I feel like that libertarians there's
there's actually some debate versus one
side has the religious and the
excommunication
has come to be the case over the past
maybe four or five years yeah I feel
like there is there has been a change to
more openness and more dialogue on the
right and I think it's a necessary
corrective to what they're seeing from
the far left I don't think that was the
case
ten years ago mm-hmm I feel like at that
time the right was locked down in the
left was kind of having these squabbles
and then it's kind of switched which
side is is recalcitrant and I think
it'll probably switch again and
eventually I'm curious since both of you
guys are outspoken atheists are is part
of your worry about all of this that it
see that this set of the postmodern
thing is very anti religious in its own
way now I know you're okay with the anti
religion part but because they've used
this set of ideas as their own religion
does that you know in any ways do you
see that as a weakness of atheism you
know to me like they've by removing all
religion altogether they had a void of
belief so now they just pick this belief
that maybe the skeptic community or the
atheist community or something needed to
do more I don't think to provide some
sort of groundwork that's kind of a
substitution hypothesis right and so my
background for the last several years
before I became a renegade feminist you
know next time we have a car issue with
Peterson yeah we should talk to him
about that this is this is I think one
of the things that people misunderstand
so there's three pillars to why people
at a psychosocial level they call it why
they believe or why they ascribe to
religions what what functions do they
play sociologically and psychologically
one is for a feeling of meaning making
purpose morality etc understanding the
world and that is kinda I think what the
substitution hypothesis often touches
upon like they have this path to find
meaning then it went away God was killed
by the postmodern deconstruction now
they don't have a meaning structure then
they look also for community how
communities are formed how they're
organized how you how you find standing
within your community that also got
deconstructed so there's an aspect to
both of those that people are trying to
fill in I don't think that that explains
extremism though
so the work that I've done looking into
the psychology of extremism is that
extremism isn't you don't go extreme
because you're looking for meaning
because you have people who are moderate
religious people all over the world who
are very very devout who aren't
extremists and you don't get extreme
necessarily just a form of community you
can those are cults where you start to
find extremism as where people the third
dimension that people go to religion for
is to have a sense of control in life
and I feel like we're in a state
probably because of many technological
advances happening so rapidly with the
internet blooming and everything so
different now than it was when I was a
kid you know Nintendo was the thing and
now that we get this you know huge
internet and indeed global connectedness
I can text people in Australia I could
get my phone right now and do it and
immediately so we've got this whole
different world now and I think what's
happened is people are feeling a loss of
control now part of that's going to come
because there's been this massive
deconstruction of institutions alongside
it but I feel like the extremism that
you see comes less from a meaning-making
place and more from a feeling out of
control place because when you feel out
of control you try to lock things down
and so I think that actually if you want
to look at like a big political kind of
solution to ratchet things down is it's
that it's very important right now that
we start trying to look at things that
will actually succeed in giving people a
greater sense that society is under
control a culture where sure as hell
isn't that and then the you know being
politically panicked whether it's the
Obama's in office and he's going to ruin
the universe from the conservative side
or Trump's an office he's gonna ruin the
universe from the liberal side whatever
it is that panic isn't a feeling of
control it's a feeling of being out of
control and that's why these issues
carry existential concern for people and
they there go so extreme so I think it's
I think that both the community and the
meaning-making structures are relevant
but to combined they probably explain
less than 20% of what we're seeing with
these kind of postmodern religions or
whatever and most of it at least in
their extremist forms where they matter
like hipsters are postmodern religion
and who cares who cares but where it
gets troublesome is where you have
people who feel like they're out of
control and if they don't exert
authoritarian control everything is
going to be terrible and so I think that
it's more of more an axis of control
than an axis of meaning-making
although it is more difficult to find
meaning in a world where you don't just
have this grand sweeping narrative of
whether it's religion whether it's
nationalism whether it's whatever it is
Western values is a big one right so I
think you know Brett Weinstein I saw was
tweeting about this the other day I
think there's there's a thing where we
all had this shared narrative of what it
means to be American or the shared
narrative what it means to be spreading
democracy abroad or whatever the thing
was you know this Western thing and the
even if you were religious or not
religious you could lock into that and
there was this kind of shared meaning
this so that's the one I would be
thinking is the most scary that we're
deconstructing the fact that these
people are you know so focused on race
or so focused on gender etc is one thing
but the fact that they're so focused on
being anti Western centric everything
that the West did is imbued with
dominance and colonialism and power and
it's always trying to maintain itself so
that's the thing we need to deconstruct
most that's the scariest idea yeah all
right Pete bring us home on a hopeful
note that we can not only turn the tide
but we can get enough people to be brave
enough and the emails won't come
anonymously and that we can restore some
some sanity right
matter of fact not only not only can we
do this but we are doing it people are
starting to respectfully speak out in
their classes people are starting to
sign their names to to petitions and
letters of support and people are
starting to genuinely attempt to be
honest broker sort of conversation after
it a minimum of five years of feeling
that they couldn't speak openly or they
couldn't speak freely so there's no
question at all that the tide is turning
and that something has changed in the
air I think that then the next steps
forward are that not only do we continue
to question but within the class within
the academic environment but we also do
so in a way that's civil and polite and
respectful we never want to lose that in
our society and we've seen the
consequences of that already so reason
has been slapped around and people feel
rightly so that they haven't been able
to speak out and in a way that
accords with their conscience and the
step to get back to those values I think
is to continue to attempt to be civil
and have an honest conversation with
somebody and if you're met with rage or
anger the response is not to meet
someone through age or anger
I'll keep doing it if you guys keep
doing it fair we'll keep doing it and
we're not quitting alright follow these
guys on Twitter it's at conceptual James
and at Peter Bogosian and we'll link to
where you want me to link to one of the
videos mike-mike Naina's youtube channel
is the place to go if you want to see
what we're up to what we've been up to
what we've done what he's putting out
it's all in the same theme he's his
YouTube channels our hub and great don't
miss it we're gonna have a link to that
right down below
[Music]